hello reboots are symptomatic of a
fundamental lack of originality in
hollywood
have you no shame here's your check for
the animaniacs reboot you sellouts
it's
[Music]
all right guys there's a lot of pressure
on our first lines
wait don't make sure it's good first
maybe something reminiscent of the first
season
22 years later and i'm still a knockout
i've tried online dating but i keep
getting catfished
how do i know she's even real
this tablet contains the sum of all
human knowledge
all human knowledge and one easy to
swallow tablet
quantum mechanics quinoa wraps queen bay
we've missed so much
oh sounds like an odyssey
my sandwich
just where i left it
gekko turn on the black light
[Music]
nothing unusual there gee brian
what do you want to do tonight the same
thing we do every night pinkie
try to take over the world we
found party
i am the pegasus i come bearing horrible
tidings of war from the dead
yeah less talky more flappy
[Music]
now the adoration pours in
[Music]
nerve
[Music]
you